an audiophile of liz trust has been
leaked in which she's heard saying
british workers need to graft more in
order for the uk to become a fully
prosperous country let's bring in our
political correspondent mario rory is
with me here on set murray this just
broke uh
in the last half an hour or so and uh
pretty embarrassing for los trust i
think it is and i think you know i've
been speaking to uh liz trust campaign
officials kind of off the record as well
and they're very keen to say this is not
a story it's not going to hurt her but i
do think a lot of people might find this
slightly problematic you want somebody
who wants to be the next prime minister
basically saying to an extent that
people don't work hard enough in this
country people won't feel very good
about that also we already had you know
there was a scandal a few uh weeks ago
on sky news breakfast show where a tory
minister said uh something slightly
similar that people basically just used
to work harder or work more hours to be
able to get themselves out of poverty so
it kind of chimes with that same tone
that same rhetoric around people just
need to work harder and i think in a
cost of living crisis when people are
struggling to just you know put food in
the table and do really basic things i
think it's not going to go down well
we've got a statement from a
spokesperson from a trust campaign
source they said
these half a decade old comments lack
context but one thing that is clear
today is ever
is that we need to boost productivity
which leads to higher wages a better
quality of life for workers rights
across the uk as prime minister liz will
deliver an economy that is high wage
high growth low tax so they're very much
trying to kind of sell this as actually
it's not as controversial as it looks
she's focused on increasing productivity
which would boost the economy and that's
all about her kind of branding when it
comes to growth and her her her branding
when it comes to trying to be the next
prime minister but i don't think this is
going to end well i've also been
speaking to some tory mps who are
backing liz trust and kind of behind the
scenes they're telling me they don't
think it's going to harm her chances but
the members they think the members won't
be upset by this but they think that
labour and the opposition will use this
as a stick to beat her with building up
more ammunition ahead of the next uh
election uh in the very least uh mario
thanks so much for bringing us that